hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in Section seven in the introduction of
being in time Martin Heidegger is going
to elaborate for us a at least
preliminary conception of what this term
phenomenology signifies and when we hear
this if we if we aren't used to thinking
about this in a rather rigorous way we
are probably going to be a bit misled in
in part because the word phenomenon
already has senses and we are accustomed
to thinking in terms of other ologies so
he wants to clarify this for us from the
beginning and I should also mention that
within this text phenomenology and
ontology the way that Heidegger is using
them in understanding them really are
describing the same ultimate method or
activity so he tells us that with the
guiding question of the meaning of being
the investigation arrives at the
fundamental question of philosophy in
general so what we're dealing with here
is not just a branch of philosophy but
you might say an inquiry into the very
meaning of what philosophy is doing so
all the other branches would be to some
degree illuminated by this so he says
the treatment of this question is
phenomenological and so he says with
this term the treatise dictates for
itself neither a standpoint nor a
direction because here's a key point
phenomenology is neither of these and
can never be as long as it understands
itself now there is an implication there
that of course phenomenology can be
turned into something that actually
doesn't understand itself it can be
appropriated it can be reduced it can be
turned into something that is no longer
true to its own origins and spirit so he
says the expression phenomenology
signifies Prime
Merilee a concept of what of a method of
an approach of a fundamental way of
going about things so he says it does
not characterize the what of the objects
of philosophical research in terms of
their content but the how of this
research and and Heidegger is going to
make this point at several times the
distinction between the what and the how
so what does he tell us that about this
whole business of phenomenology that's
very nice in terms of preliminary per
you know in ambulation czar around the
the concept but what is phenomenology
then so he's going to first examine the
concept of phenomenon we've given that a
discussion already and then the concept
of logos theology and then there's a
final section where he comes to the
preliminary concept of phenomenology so
he says when we bring to mind can creat
lis what we have exhibited for ourselves
in phenomenon and logos were struck by
an inter relation between what is meant
by those terms what what is the the
content what is the core of phenomena
find out a phenomenon right if I know na
is the Greek and then logos or the ology
for us he says the expression it a
phenomenology could be formulated in
Greek as legging that's the infinitive
of the verb that logos is coming from
Toth I know men they says but legging as
we've discovered means apple fauna sigh
and that means to reveal to bring to
presence to show forth for the those who
are looking for things and this is done
through speech all right so he says to
let what shows itself be seen from
itself not just to be shown in light of
something else but to be shown
itself what it is how it is what kind of
thing it is also in its relations to
other things so he says that's the
formal meaning of the type of research
that calls itself phenomenology and
that's where we get this maxim this
famous saying back to the things
themselves right so what are the things
themselves and how do we go to the
things themselves
Heidegger by the way he will say this
that several points here wants to
caution us against thinking that this is
some sort of naive just look around and
you've got the things themselves right
in front of you it may actually take
quite a lot of work to get the things to
reveal themselves as they are in
themselves but there's a fundamental
optimism here about the possibility of
grasping what things are now the next
thing that he talks about in this
section is being covered up why does he
talk about that
this has to do in part with heidegger's
conception of truth as Alafaya
uncovering or discovering or bringing
out of forgetfulness or concealment and
it also has to do with the activity that
the phenomenologist is engaged in so he
says what is it that phenomenology is to
let be seen he says manifested ly it's
something that does not show itself
initially and for the most part
something that is concealed otherwise
you wouldn't need to go about looking
for it would you if it was entirely
there on the surface you wouldn't need a
method so this is a method that applies
to things that are in some respect
concealed or he's going to say here
covered up and he says what remains
concealed in an exceptional sense or
what falls back and is covered up again
or shows itself only in a distorted
is not this or that being but rather the
being of beings now is this the being of
beings in the sense of you know sort of
capital be the totality that runs
through everything no no he's not
talking about that but he is talking
about the being of beings how something
really is in itself so he tells us
phenomenology is a way of access to and
the demonstrative manner of damage
determination of what is to become the
theme of ontology and so he says the
phenomenon phenomenological concept of
phenomenon itself showing means the
being of beings this shelfs this self
showing is nothing arbitrary nor is it
something like an appearing the being of
beings is least of all something behind
which something else stands he says
nothing stands behind the phenomena of
phenomenology rather being covered up is
where we have to look and he says
there's different ways in which
phenomena can be covered up and here we
have something like a typology that he's
setting out it's really got two
different dimensions to it he talks
about what is undiscovered what is at
some point in time not yet discovered by
anybody nobody even has an inkling that
it's there quite often he says there is
neither knowledge nor lack of knowledge
about it as soon as we have a lack of
knowledge that we're aware of as a lack
of knowledge now we actually have
something that we can begin to discover
the second thing that he talks about is
buried over now what does he mean by
that
he says a phenomenon can be discovered
but then got covered up again the third
thing that he talks about is distortion
and he says it's the most frequent and
most dangerous kind because here the
possibilities of being deceived and
being misled are particularly
pertinacious and he talks about the
tendency for us to see things within a
system
that ends up distorting what it is that
the system is supposed to be applying to
you can think of so many different
systems and examples
Heidegger doesn't give you examples here
but I think it would be worthwhile for
us to dwell on a few of these I'm going
to use something that Heidegger very
infrequently talks about and that is
romantic love now as a child you can
certainly read fairytales and of course
you can be exposed to all sorts of
influences that can you know make you
sort of precociously involved in that
but for many children that's something
that is in the realm of the undiscovered
until suddenly they do discover it then
it can be buried over think of if you're
old or even middle-aged what your first
crush was like what that experience was
like for you you might have to do a lot
of work to try to recover that because
you've done so much living and
experiencing and and rethinking the
stuff that's involved in your life since
that time I know I certainly would I can
cognitively bring it to the mind right
away but I would have to actually do a
lot of work to recapture the effectivity
of it it's buried over all right
Distortion it's Valentine's Day you know
you're supposed to be doing something
with your significant other on an Allen
tines day because that's what everybody
does now this is a great example of
something else that Heidegger calls the
you know average everydayness as well
but that's a different concept
maybe romantic love as whatever it
happens to be whatever kind of being or
beings it is is thereby distorted by
being placed in that perspective
hopefully those examples give you some
idea of what he's talking about here now
he tells us they have a different set of
modalities as well they can be
accidental or they can be
Cerie so he says there are accidental
coverings necessary ones the latter
grounded in the enduring nature of the
discovered and here he gives us a
caution he says it's possible for every
phenomenological concept and proposition
drawn from genuine origins to degenerate
when communicated in a statement we have
to be very careful not to lose sight of
what is being provided to us in
phenomenology or through phenomenology
or by phenomenology not to simply take
it for granted as if it's some sort of
commodity that we can put in our pocket
or a set of data that we can say put on
a multiple-choice test of some sort if
we do that we're actually losing it and
covering up is taking place the next
thing that he talks about that's useful
for understanding what phenomenology is
is this distinction between phenomenal
and phenomenological and he says now we
can actually give these fixed meanings
he says what is given an explicable in
the way we encounter the phenomenon is
called phenomenal what is given what we
encounter right and is explicable in the
way we encounter the phenomenon that's
the phenomenal we we encounter this
constantly you are engaging in it right
now and so am I so what is the
phenomenal logic coulvet it's similar to
his distinction between ontic and
ontological or existential and
existential he says that the everything
that belongs to the manner of indication
and explication and constitutes the
conceptual tools this research requires
that is what we call phenomenological so
he says phenomenon in the
phenomenological understanding is always
just what constitutes being so where can
we go from here
here's where he begins to talk again
about ontology
and he brings in another term that is
particularly important ontology is what
we're doing in doing high daguerreian
phenomenology we're also engaged in what
he's going to call here hermeneutics
that's a rather fancy term for something
that we're a bit more Oh
familiar with as interpretation and
interpretation is when we get something
and we call some meaning of it out of it
or we place it within a framework or we
make sense of it or we question it so
that we can better understand it and
there's there's always some sort of
back-and-forth and there's always some
contribution on our own side many people
are very afraid of interpretations
because they think that oh if I ever
engage in interpretation I will not have
objectivity and objectivity is the you
know see naquan known of anything being
scientific it really depends on what
we're actually studying the human areas
of study require interpretation and so
Heidegger tells us that hermeneutics is
essential hermeneutics is not just a
discipline it's the way that design
exists in relation to itself in relation
to its world in relation to others so he
says phenomenology of design is
hermeneutics in the original
signification of that word which
designates the work of interpretation
and then he says since discovery of the
meaning of being and the basic
structures of design in general exhibits
the horizon for every further
ontological research into beings unlike
design that is since this inquiry of
fundamental ontology indicates something
that structures other regional ontology
which is what we call the sciences and
disciplines right he says the present
hermeneutic the one he's developing is
at the same time hermeneutics in the
sense the
works out the condition of the
possibility of every ontological
investigation he's using what we call
their transcendental language and a
little bit just after that he's going to
talk about the transcendental 'ti of the
inquiry he's engaged in he brings up a
third point about hermeneutics saying
since design has an ontological priority
over all other beings as a being in the
possibility of existence hermeneutics is
the analysis of what he's going to call
the existential 'ti of existence now you
might hear that and say this sounds very
circular the existential 'ti of
existence what does he mean there
remember that the existential has to do
with not just what exists but the
framework the structures of existence
including our relation to it existence
is for us as design as human beings so
the existential 'ti of existence means
it's fundamental structures as what is
for us not just what exists in a bare
sense so he goes on he says a few other
things that are of interest here I
mentioned the transcend the
transcendental 'ti says the
transcendence of the being of design is
a distinctive one in it lies the
possibility and necessity of the most
radical individuation we as human beings
are capable of greater individuation
than other beings are then he says every
disclosure of being as the transcend
ends that which transcends is
transcendental knowledge
so phenomenological truth is
transcendental truth so he tells us here
to bring it to a close ontology and
phenomenology are not two different
disciplines which among others belong to
philosophy both of these
actually characterize what is at the
very core often misunderstood of genuine
philosophy from its beginnings all the
way up to the present and we also have
this third term in there as well that's
vitally important of hermeneutics so
we've got phenomenology ontology and
hermeneutics all as ways of describing
this approach that Heidegger is taking
in being in time
you